he blocks me
so this is this happens with anybody of
any rank is blocked
so what you've got to do is on this side
of the body to that side of the body
you've got to float
watch this foot
hmm now the foot's got to be ready for
the next position before the next
position gets there
and that's why that's why
if you don't move it
and then step in it'll flop
you know I've used probably years but
pinball games the ball goes bing bing
you've got to be that ball so depending
on the person's how they feel to you
or depend how whether this goes outwards
straight ahead
and it all depends on where their arm is
in length
so
don't reduce in but you know but make it
so it's strong
if it's strong I can perhaps fight
against it so scientists are used to
show it like this he used to make a ring
and he used to do
so for years you'd think oh that's
because he's a night then isn't it
but what he's showing us is you can't
take it anywhere you have to go where
that is so by making the ring we work
out so we're gonna we're gonna do this
ring
so come here
from this side to that side you you move
you make a ring
so I'm just wanting you to see that what
you won't be able to do is put the dots
together you won't about to say well how
do I do that the minute I grip
foreign
you'll get the same feeling on the shear
Navy you'll go through what are called
hot and cold spots you go through
difficult
so if you're third and above I'd like
you to switch from hands to ring like I
did
from hands to rings
that's the best life
okay
I was saying Thursday night as long as
it's Joy actually bigger than me oh I
got it wrong again
yes
messages
but it gets frustrating so we've got two
seniors here just
to see
nothing's wrong there's nothing wrong
as it comes Upon A flowing blind stops
and then he's off again
all right
flying flying flying stop and they're
not going to go off it goes again
that stop gives his partner time to go
what are you going to do to me
but no no sense I don't get fighting
anymore I'm the dormant you know I've
seen it all
he'll be fighting because it's happening
to him
and that's what we can't do if it's
harmonious
and he's not going to be fine
foreign
I can do it
where's the spot
so those were dies
did you say stop
oh
and then there was a little stop on
there and you see how difficult it's
comes
weapons weapons and more weapons
there's feeling
and there's sensing I'm on the sensory
perceptions now you'll be on the feeling
assumption so you're on the feeling
perception so when you get here you go
foreign
I've got to go in a minute I'll give him
a hard time as well you know and that's
about the the quality of our
dream that come along with me because
I'm sensing
oh I know it's quick
but you said I'm sensing how much I can
stretch this man out or how much I might
step into danger so that's not your time
yet for this
so it's a martial art
but we're trying to make it so you take
their mind no sense he said you must use
a temmie to take their mind
I'm using a temmie without showing a
fist
because he's going
well there's no point in me resisting
because there's there's nothing to
resist
so slowly
here
again because I've taken it too far it's
what Danny was talking about earlier
I've now taken it too far so for me to
get there
could do what I've learned in muroti
Dory
and soften my lower body
so that's the sort of thing I do when
you get a block I'll just go to another
room another room in the body and do it
then we've got
a float
turn
ing difficult is because you've tried to
stretch them out
at this point it's too much
and there's a stop and they're not very
difficult
is what I'm doing
of
coming here and I'm drawing this not
anymore towards you
towards such as
I'll get to a point
your mind tells you that you need to
keep cutting it what I'm saying is I
actually backed off
my back office as if I I cut a corner of
the circle because
to do the circle
now
I can't do
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
stop it being a circle technique and I'm
going to make a
rainbow technique
I don't want to give you all this
information it's a it's good for my
films anyhow